We're eternals for 7 000 years we've
protected humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or any war
all the other terrible things throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere until
now you hear that eternal's assembled
Hi hello hey who's your gardener
This planet and these people
have changed all of us
When you love something
you protect it for eternity
marvel studios eternals what's your superpower
you know that your babysitting
privileges are completely revoked
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or any war
all the other terrible things throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in any human
conflicts unless deviants are involved by who
Eternals explores the very creation of the
marvel universe itself the film also deals
very much with the aftermath of avengers
4 and the state the world is in five of
the eternals are more of the thinkers and
the other five are the stronger fighters
the eternals are these remarkably
superpowered characters
but also a dysfunctional family unit this is what
the end of the world looks like at least we have
front row seats you know what's never saved the
planet you're sarcasm the person to bring that
together was academy award winner chloe jaw we go
on these emotional journeys with these eternals
to figure out who they are and what it
means to be human her vision is so clear
it's not the typical place it's not the typical
shots it's not the typical cast everybody looks
different everybody sounds different a
lot of people are gonna see themselves
as superheroes for the first time really is an
epic global film the scope and the scale of it
is huge it's so exciting to be part of something
that really feels new the impact that eternals
will have on the mcu will be nothing less than
redefining the cinematic universe entirely
Welcome back everyone big surprise marvel
just dropped a whole bunch of brand new
eternals trailer footage right after i just did
an eternals video so we'll break it all down they
also clarified in a bunch of interviews what's
going on with avengers 5 marvel phase 4 and what
eternals is doing inside the mcu they even talked
about the post credit scenes in the movie i know
everybody's got theories about post-credit scenes
hoping to see some galactus in there somewhere
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos the movies
coming out really soon i will do a giveaway
for movie tickets all you have to do to enter
is just be a subscriber and leave all your
predictions about eternals on the video
they focus a lot more on the footage about them
talking about thanos the events of avengers end
game where the eternals were why they didn't help
out i've talked about that in my previous videos
but here's another really big question that kevin
feige and the marvel producers answered that i
know you guys have been asking did the eternals
get snapped by thanos in avengers infinity war
in the way that the marvel people explained it
they did not get snapped mostly because of the
way they were engineered by the celestials also
probably a little bit of luck there too under
normal circumstances the whole idea is that the
snap was supposed to erase half of all life in
the universe and the eternals are supposed to be
alive so theoretically they'd still be susceptible
to the snap but apparently the way the celestials
made them the way they work are just so op
that none of them got snapped they just had to sit
and watch it all play out from a distance and when
sersi is explaining to kit harrington's character
dane whitman why they didn't help out because the
celestials told them not to unless it involved
deviants there's a brand new version of that
scene where she clarifies on top of that saying
they told us not to interfere until now so the
way that the marvel producers explain the deviants
in the context of the film i'm just paraphrasing
what they said here this is the deviants of these
parasitic aliens who go from planet to planet as
they kill the apex predators on a given planet
they sort of take the characteristics of those
predators and wipe out intelligent life the
eternals are heroes so they've come to earth
to eradicate the deviants and allow humanity to
thrive i've already kind of explained the larger
context for this too the deviants were created
by the celestials as well but before the eternals
the deviants just went rogue on the celestials and
that's why they created the eternals to get rid of
them then they say in present day we meet a couple
of the eternals like sersi and sprite who are
living in london we see a lot of footage of them
walking around in present-day london sersi works
at the natural history museum in london with dane
whitman and that's how they got to know each other
and started their relationship but the scene where
they're saving kit harrington's character like she
transmutes the bus that's during a deviant
attack like you see ikaris fly up in the air
shoot one with laser beams they say that that's
actually supposed to be the first deviant attack
in the last 5,000 years so for 5,000 years they've
all just kind of been living out amongst humans
fracturing as a group because they're not really
needed that much anymore and when these deviants
come back in present day they've evolved over
time and so the part of the mystery of the film
is finding out how it is they evolved why
they evolved and what they're trying to do
but you actually see a separate scene from later
during what seems like the big final battle in
this area here around the volcano that's exploding
you see athena's character fighting crow and it
sounds like the deviants are trying to use the
emergence to destroy the planet destroy all life
on the planet i've already talked a lot about
the emergence the whole idea that there's this
deeper layer to it is the celestials are trying
to basically hatch another celestial and that's
why it's so important that there was so much
cosmic energy released with all the snaps from
avengers infinity war and avengers end game the
marvel people went on to say that obviously a big
part of the film is explaining the history of the
celestials we've gotten little bits of that like
in the guardians of the galaxy movie with issan
the searcher they said that they wanted to explore
their role in the creation of life across the
galaxy so obviously this goes beyond kang in the
multiverse war and what he talked about the way
he controls the timeline from start to end they
also made another funny reference to avengers end
game where they say that the movie also explores
what the celestial's end game is for all this
like if they are immortal and they're going around
creating life around the universe what is their
true endgame like i said i think that plays into
the idea of what's going on with the emergence the
fact that they're trying to create more celestials
and it just takes millions and billions of
years sometimes because there's not much
cosmic energy around as there was during the big
bang there's a bunch more scenes of them talking
about the avengers like ikaris saying eternals
assemble salma hayek also clarified the eternal's
relationship with the avengers characters because
they do kind of re-contextualize some of the
avengers characters during the eternals movie
based on the way the eternals experience history
it's the same thing they did in the shangshi movie
with the iron man character in the mandarin like
you kind of recontextualized the events of the
original iron man film based on what you learned
about wenwoo's history and the fact that he was
sort of pulling the strings behind everything
that led up to iron man winding up in the cave and
becoming iron man in the first place so what they
said is the eternals obviously have been watching
everything play out over the last 7,000 years just
watching humans evolve and then watching the
events of the infinity saga movies play out
because they couldn't really intervene but most
of the eternals characters are actually fairly
impressed with what the avengers have accomplished
like some of them are full-blown avengers fanboys
in fact some of you spotted this in the first
teaser trailer so kingo is a bollywood star so
he's earned a lot of money he has this private
jet that they're flying on here if you look in
the background he actually owns captain america's
original shield from his uso tour just to give you
an idea how much of a fanboy of the avengers some
of them are salma hayek also clarified that she is
the only eternal that can communicate with the
celestials like you kind of see that happening
in this scene here when she's using her abilities
but then later in the trailer obviously you see
sersi communicating with them so the early theory
is that ajak dies at some point in the film and
then sersi sort of takes over that role from
her so you see this giant structure behind her
here but then as it slowly changes it turns into
what looks like the blackness of space so it seems
like she's going here to communicate with airshim
the judge when that's happening the marvel people
also confirmed that these eternals in particular
are from a planet called olympia which is a play
on their comic book origin where their bases
in olympia greece near mount olympus speaking
of their giant celestial spaceship in this big
final battle scene around this erupting volcano
you actually see their ship crashing to earth
like something happens to destroy their ship
either they crash it on purpose or it's just part
of their fight with the deviants that winds up
destroying it or they're trying to use it to stop
the emergence but then there are several other
scenes where you see more of the actual eternals
abilities so the really cool thing about fasto's
character here too is that it actually looks like
he's got some very iron man inspired abilities
although the way they play it here because
he's so old it really would be him inspiring
the other modern day avengers characters but it's
just another way to sort of link them to what's
happening in present day like oh they've kind of
influenced things from behind the scenes without
realizing it again same thing that happened in
the shangshi movie with wen wu being alive for
the last thousand years influencing the course of
human history and speaking of the timeline there
have been so many questions about exactly when
this movie takes place at least in present day
after avengers end game so the producers clarified
that we're supposed to assume that this takes
place like the actual emergence here is happening
at the same time spider-man far from home is
happening but the funny thing about eternals
taking place at the same time as spider-man
far from home is that a lot of spider-man far from
home takes place in the london area and a lot of
the eternals movie takes place in the london area
so you're like wait a minute when this giant drone
battle with mysterio is happening what are all the
eternals doing in the london area like wouldn't
they be looking at this and watching this all play
out on their screens a couple of the really cool
details in here too there are two post credit
scenes they confirm now when they say two post
credit scenes i think what they mean is is that
there's a mid credit scene and then an actual post
credit scene which is pretty standard for the
big marvel movies same thing with the shangshi
movie mid credit scene than a big ass post-credits
scene i know you have all kinds of theories about
what's going on just because of the cosmic stuff
they're playing in with the eternals movie it'll
probably be a cosmic related avengers 5 teaser
kind of like the way that shanxi's post credit
scene was a big cosmic teaser for avengers 5. just
tune your theories accordingly they also clarified
what's going on with kit harington's black knight
character as well and what the future for him
inside the mcu is going to be so they said for the
most part in this movie kit harrington is mostly
just going to be dane whitman and they mostly just
have easter eggs for his true origin as the black
knight in the ebony blade in his armor the actual
blade itself isn't supposed to play a factor in
the movie the producers basically said that we
don't do the ebony blade in this movie we're
doing it in the sequels if you have any other
big questions or any other easter eggs that you
spotted in this footage that i didn't talk about
in the video just write it below in the comments
i'll name a giveaway winner when i post my next
marvel video i'm working on a brand new guardians
of the galaxy 3 adam warlock video there were some
really cool announcements that happened recently
while you wait for that click here for that brand
new eternals avengers trailer video with a whole
bunch of avengers and game footage and click here
to learn more about kit harington's black knight
character thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!